quizás aún más interesante que encontrar
la inversa de una matriz es es tratar de
determinar cuándo una inversa de la
matriz no existe o cuando ésta es
indefinida y una matriz cuadrada para la
que no hay inversa de las cuales una
inversa no está definida se le denomina
matriz singular así que vamos a pensar
lo que es esto y cómo se aplica a los
diferentes problemas que hemos planteado
ya anteriormente utilizando matrices así
que si tuviera una matriz de dos por dos
digo de esto es un ejemplo sencillo pero
o trasladar estos argumentos a cualquier
matriz de cualquier tamaño mientras sea
cuadrada digamos que esta es la matriz
abc de ok
cuál es la inversa de esta matriz
esperemos que esto ya sea de naturaleza
familiar para ustedes bueno pero esto es
uno entre el determinante de a
la matriz adjunta verdad y en este caso
la matriz de adjunta es de a
intercambiamos esos y luego a los otros
les cambiamos el signo verdad y nos
queda menos 6 b así que mi pregunta es
qué haría que esta expresión completa no
está definida bueno no importa lo que
tengo dentro de la matriz verdad aquí
todas estas son números que simplemente
los intercambios les cambia el signo
esto no tiene ningún problema por lo que
crearía un problema si intentáramos
dividir por cero aquí es decir si el
determinante de la matriz de de a fuera
cero fuera nula así que una inversa éste
no está no está definida
no está definida
si y sólo si y en matemáticas ya saben
que para resumirlo lo escribimos como si
con doble y pero bueno si sólo si el
determinante de la matriz a es igual a
cero y la otra forma de ver esto es que
si el determinante de la matriz es igual
a cero entonces la inversa no está
definida porque tendría yo que dividir
entre el determinante y si en cero pues
no se puede verdad así que vamos a
pensar en términos más conceptuales de
los problemas que hemos visto qué
pasaría si el determinante es igual a
cero porque porque no puedo determinar
una inversa así que que es que el
determinante sea cero para empezar bueno
el determinante de a es igual a a por de
menos
b por c
a de menos de porsche así que esta
matriz es singular y no tiene inversa si
este numerito de aquí si esta expresión
es igual a cero así que déjenme
escribirlo
a d es igual abc es lo mismo verdad
pasamos veces sumando del otro lado y
por ejemplo podríamos decir también que
esto es válido si a / b es igual a se
entrevé esto si pasamos la b dividiendo
del lado izquierdo y la de dividiendo
del lado derecho verdad entonces si esta
relación entre los elementos lo que son
las filas de la de la matriz si si las
proporciones son iguales el singular
ahora por ejemplo pueden ver que también
si entre c es igual a b sobre de ok
igual pasándola se dividiendo el lado
izquierdo y la de dividiendo del lado
derecho en este caso tenemos la
proporción de los de las columnas verdad
que tenemos en la matriz hecho estas dos
expresiones son son equivalentes pero la
proporción a sobre se iguala b sobre b
esto nos estaría dando esta relación que
el determinante se anula es decir que se
hace cero pero esto se traduce en algo
conocido para algunos problemas por
ejemplo digamos que quiero ver el
problema
vamos a decir que tuvimos esta matriz
que esta matriz representa un problema
de una de un sistema de ecuaciones
lineales entonces tengo a bs d
que multiplica
a x de que son mis dos variables
desconocidas y quiero ver que esto es
para qué valores xy es igual a efe
ok donde son constantes entonces si
tenemos esta ecuación representada por
esta matriz esto se traduciría a que a
equis verdad multiplicando el primer el
primer renglón por la columna de esa x
más bella igual a él y luego
multiplicando la segunda fila perdón se
x más de y es igual a
muy bien y nos gustaría ver donde estos
dos se cruzan verdad esto es lo que
estamos diciendo geométricamente
encontrar las soluciones ver dónde se
cruzan las líneas que representan cada
una de las ecuaciones entonces vamos a
ponerlo en en términos de pendiente con
ordenada al origen esto simplemente
despejando y es igual a y es igual a
menos a sobre b que multiplica a x más
es sobre b verdad simplemente es
passarella x restando y luego dividimos
todo entre ve muy bien y entonces la
segunda ecuación de la segunda ecuación
que tenemos resolvemos para allí y
tenemos que ya es igual a menos
no sé sobre d
por equis
este es x lo pasamos al lado derecho
verdad más
efe sobre de muy bien así que vamos a
pensar en esto vamos a pensar en esto
aquí probablemente debería cambiar de
color porque
confuso pero vamos a pensar que en estas
dos ecuaciones cómo se vería si tenemos
esta condición que estoy en marcando en
verde y dijimos si esto se cumple
entonces no hay determinante y por lo
tanto la matriz a no tiene inversa ok no
se puede resolver entonces esta ecuación
en teoría y vamos a ver porque esta
inversa no existe vamos a suponer si
esto es cierto no tendremos determinante
pero como se ve esto intuitivamente en
términos de las ecuaciones bueno si
entre b es igual a c / d porque es decir
si estos dos numeritos son iguales estas
dos líneas tienen la misma pendiente ok
así que estas dos expresiones son
diferentes simplemente por la ordenada
al origen verdad donde se intersectan
con el eje pero no importa el chiste es
que como tienen la misma pendiente
entonces las líneas son paralelas
permíteme dibujar estos digamos aquí
están mis ejes ok entonces de esta línea
de acá arriba déjenme
déjenme pintarla ok no sé como sea pero
bueno supongamos que es de este estilo
esta es la primera línea
su intersección con el eje es este
verdad sobre b que es la ordenada al
origen bien esta es esta línea esta de
azul y luego la segunda línea déjenme
hacerlo con otro color
ok no sé si vaya a estar por arriba o
por abajo el chiste es que tienen que
ser paralelas y se verían algo así
ok y esta línea se intersecta en este
punto que es f sobre d
sobre d
así que entrevé efe sobre d son términos
que podrían ser o no iguales por el
punto es que las líneas nunca se cruzan
bueno no se cruzan si estos términos
entre b y f sobre y son distintos verdad
entonces realmente no puedo resolver la
ecuación si son iguales a entre b y c /
de entonces las líneas son paralelas y
entonces no se intersectan pero tú
podrías decir oye bueno qué tal que / b
y f sobre b son iguales verdad entonces
en realidad estamos hablando de la misma
línea y no sólo se cruzan sino que se
intersectan en un número infinito de
puntos de hecho son la misma línea
verdad entonces no tendría una solución
a esta ecuación tendría una infinidad
sería cierto para muchísimos valores así
que de cualquier forma yo no tendría una
solución única entonces si la matriz es
singular las las líneas que representan
son paralelas o en realidad es la misma
línea para el caso en que la ordenada al
origen sean iguales no
entonces en ese caso se cortaría o se
intersectan en un número infinito de
puntos y así es como tiene sentido que
la inversa no está bien definida así que
vamos a pensar ahora en el contexto de
combinaciones de vectores lo que quería
utilizar para borrar
bien
así que cuando pensamos en este problema
en términos de combinaciones lineales de
vectores se puede pensar que es así
verdad digamos esto es
este es el vector hace
por equis más el vector de por qué
y esto debe ser igual
efe al vector efe así que vamos a pensar
un poco lo estamos diciendo hay alguna
combinación de los vectores de estos de
hace y bd hay alguna combinación que me
df pero acabamos de decir que aquí no
tenemos una inversa debido a que el
determinante es 0 entonces si el
determinante 0 ya sabemos que en nuestra
situación a sobre c es igual a beso
breve aunque entonces a sobre a a
perdona sobre se es igual a ver sobre de
que nos dice eso
déjenme dibujarlo
y tal vez los números aquí
también vamos a obtener intuición a
partir de esto dibujamos el primer
cuadrante va a suponer que ambos
vectores están en el primer cuadrante de
dibujarlo de esta forma
el vector hace digamos déjenme hacerlo
en un color distinto voy a señalar dónde
está el vector hace así que aquí está el
punto a él
punto
ok entonces este es el vector hacer
quiero dejar todo esto limpio entonces
el vector hace es este
y le ponemos su flechita muy bien cuál
sería el vector verde
este vamos a hacerlo con amarillo bueno
el vector verde lo podría dibujar podría
haber varios casos déjenme ponerlo
arbitrariamente pero estamos suponiendo
que el determinante el determinante en
este caso es 0 verdad entonces el
determinante de la matriz es 0 y si no
hay determinante sabemos que a sobre c
es igual a b sobre d
otra manera de ver es que sé sobre d es
igual a d
se sobre a perdón es igual a d sobre b
así que si ambos empiezan en el punto
cero quiere decir que no importa que
tengan una magnitud distinta pero van en
la misma dirección verdad entonces por
ejemplo si aquí está b
y aquí está d
en el vector bebé va a estar por aquí
verdad a lo mejor puede tener magnitud
distinta al rosita pero lo importante es
que van a apuntar van a apuntar en la
misma dirección que hace que el vector
se va esencialmente por encima del otro
verdad va a tener la misma dirección que
el vector anterior pero bueno va a tener
una magnitud diferente verdad se podría
se podría tener la misma magnitud quién
sabe así que la pregunta es si podemos
hacer una combinación lineal de estos
dos vectores que en el vector
efe pero por ejemplo supongan si usted
es que este es el vector sf ok
en un color diferente
el vector efe
está contado y flecha así que mi
pregunta de si estos dos vectores que
están en la misma dirección quizás con
distinta magnitud hay alguna manera de
que al sumarlos por cierto por cierta
constante podamos generar al vector
efe y todo lo que vamos a hacer si
sumamos estos dos vectores el ac y el
bebé simplemente vamos a obtener puntos
de la misma dirección verdad no se puede
llegar al vector
efe porque necesitamos una dirección
diferente así que en este en este
problema no tenemos una solución verdad
sólo si el f estuviera en la misma
dirección que hace vd entonces podríamos
tener una solución pero en este caso no
entonces en dicho caso tendríamos una
infinidad de soluciones pero si el
vector es ligeramente diferente en
términos de su dirección entonces no hay
solución no hay combinación de este
vector no lo hay que nos dé ese vector
lf y si lo piensas un poquito bueno
quizás pueda parecer algo obvio pero
bueno tomar una suma de vectores
cualquier otro vector digamos que esté
fuera de esta línea amarilla ajá digamos
este vector
efe en realidad necesitamos empujar o
sumar por un vector distinto a otro que
esté en la línea para poder alcanzar
este naranja verdad espero espero que ya
te esté dando un poco de intuición
quizás estoy hablando un poquito en
círculos al respecto pero bueno al menos
ya sabes lo que es una matriz singular y
ya sabemos cuando no podemos encontrar
su inversa verdad y esto es bueno